Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allahala. mentions
three verses at the start of the chapter
regarding repentance to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Now the verses in the Quran
which command or discuss repentance are
incredibly numerous. However, he chose
these three verses because they are
unique in their command
of repentance.
The first verse he mentions is from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
which translates to and repent to Allah
all of you oh believers in order that
you may become successful. Notice the
wording of this verse.
And repent to Allah
all of you,
oh believers.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is speaking
in this verse not just to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to every believer
even the prophets and messengers
even the messengers of Allah. Repentance
is something that is part of belief.
This is what is understood from this
verse when Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
calls out the people of belief by their
belief.
So he is saying repent to Allah oh
believers.
This means that if you are truly a
believer,
belief will never be complete until it
is coupled with repentance.
A part a dimension of belief is
repentance to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It's an integral part of belief and it
is one of the three main pillars of the
hallmarks of the people of paradise.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala doesn't just
make repentance here an aspect of belief
but he as well makes it a critical
component and a prerequisite
for success that a person will never be
successful without
repentance being an integral part of
their lives. He says subhanahu wa ta'ala
and repent to Allah all of you oh
believers in order that you may obtain
success.
Success is not going to be had by any
man or woman
until they repent to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And we understand from this
verse that everyone
has something to repent for. Everyone is
guilty. The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said in the narration of anis
he said each human being every child of
Adam
is
a a sinner.
Now the word that he used wasn't every
human being makes mistakes. No no no he
said
meaning intentionally disobys.
Every human being is disobedient.
And the best
or the redeemable
from amongst the sinners are those who
are constantly repenting.
This narration is known to many of us.
It's often times overlooked in the way
that its words are structured.
[Silence]
He says saiam
he didn't say each human being makes
mistakes
every human being sins.
That's not what he said. He said every
human being is a sinner
constantly. Every human being is a
sinner
and the redeemable from amongst those
sinners are
those who are constantly repent
repenting.
So here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us in this verse.
He says, "And repent to Allah all of
you,
oh believers, in order that you may
obtain
success.
In surah
he mentions the third verse which is
what Allah teaches the prophet Muhammad
to tell his people
was
but in this chapter
every prophet that is mentioned
who came to his people with the message
of Islam. They all say the same thing.
What do what are the things that they
say?
Worship Allah alone. You have no other
deity, person, thing worthy of your
worship but Allah. And they each said to
their people,
seek forgiveness from your Lord and then
repent to him earnestly.
And this exact wording is what the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam used to
do every day.
Abu narrates that he heard the messenger
of Allah.
Wasam say
Abu
said, I heard the messenger of Allah sai
was say, I swear by Allah,
I do seek forgiveness from Allah and
repent to him each day 70 times.
70 times.
This number 70
70 it is one of the numbers that is used
in the Arabic language to articulate
a large amount. if I say for
instance I called you a hundred times.
Does it mean that I literally called you
100 times? No. What it means I called
you many times. A lot of times, more
times than normal when it comes to phone
calls, the word the number 70
articulates
at least 70 in the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's words.
What it really means is many many many
times more than 70. It's as if he's
saying, "I swear by Allah I do seek his
forgiveness and repent to him every day
an innumerable amount of times, a huge
number of times." And
heard the prophet sallall.am Wasallam
say
he heard the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam say each day I seek Allah's
forgiveness and repent to him 100 times.
So a lot of times many times much times
was asked what is the most virtuous
remembrance of Allah?
Is it
seeking forgiveness
or is it praise of Allah
meaning to say
alhamdulillah
or to say
or is it to say subhan Allah? Which one
is most virtuous?
He said
that you always begin
with cleaning something before trying to
beautify it. If you have a piece of
clothing, your body, you don't start
with beautifying it. You don't start
with perfume.
You start with a good shower to clean
off whatever is on it. then you start to
add adornments.
And so what he's saying
is that you can never seek forgiveness
enough times
in order to adequately prepare yourself
to be adorned with the praise of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The point here is
that these two things are mentioned
together.
What?
What is
when a person says
often times we hear the translation
I seek Allah's forgiveness. Correct. in
more or less words. But what is the
exact linguistic meaning of
and what is its relationship with
and I repent to Allah?
In the Arabic language
means to cover something.
To cover something and to protect and
conceal something. This is what means.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's name is
and
meaning that he subhanahu wa ta'ala
covers and protects
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and conceals
and from this
we call a
a mur is a police station they call
it aar because it covers and conceals
the police inside of it and it protects
them from attacks. Likewise,
which is a helmet that is worn during
battle, it's called a mvar. All from the
same root word. When a person says,
he is saying, "Oh Allah,
cover and conceal my sins of past and
protect me from the ill effects of those
sins. It's not just forgiveness of the
sin. It is forgiveness of the sin but
also that the sins are concealed from
others and concealed on the day of
judgment when a person is resurrected in
front of Allah that Allah not mention
those sins and that I am protected from
the evil effects that those sins, those
foolish mistakes I made that they affect
me in an in an ill manner. This is the
meaning of
when a person says
he is asking Allah to conceal his
mistakes
to forgive them and to protect him from
the ill effects of those mistakes.
Now when
is mentioned alone in the Quran in the
Sunnah in dua person says
It means conceal those sins and protect
and protect me from their ill effects
and forgive me for what is past and
protect me from that same sin in the
future.
However, when that is coupled with a
it is here
is for what is past and is for what is
in the future. Meaning I seek
forgiveness of what is past
and I ask Allah to protect me in what is
future of my sins. And this is the same
thing that is understood when the two
names of Allah are put together in that
way.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so these two
these two acts are often coupled
together because they include what is
passed of sin and what is to come of a
person's sin.
Hence Allah put these two together,
these two great acts of worship. And
each and every prophet and messenger
commanded his people with this
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Alhamdulillah.
I mean,